Projects like that.
And then just sharing it with the world at large,
people going like,
this is impossible.
I mean,
how many guys do you know?
That was like,
one day I'm going to do this cool thing,
but like never do it.
Right.
And so actually going after that and sharing it away,
it's like you might not want to walk across Antarctica,
but like you probably have some hope or some dream or some goal that you want to
accomplish in your life.
Like fucking go and do it.
Like get after it.
And so for me,
doing this,
it's funny,
I've,
I've started to think of myself less as an athlete and actually more of as an
artist in my canvas really is just in sports,
but creating these art projects in the world that I can create and share with
people through storytelling tope we inspire them to do that.
So what was I thinking in that first hour was,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want my art project to blow up right in my face,
but more so there was,
this was bigger than myself.
And that's really what kept me going forward.
It's like I can't let these kids in these public school classrooms think that I
could after the first hour,
like these other people that are driving inspiration from this,
hopefully like I want to do this for this larger purpose.
And honestly,
that's,
that's what really kept me going forward through the really hard times was that,
that that connection to a larger purpose of what I want to put out in the world.
And that ripple effect,
the positivity.
That's awesome.
And then of course you have a giant team that prepared,
let them,
oh yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's a lot.
Lot goes into it.
So get,
get into that,
getting to that starting line and having that doubt.
But I think,
I mean on one level it's also,
it's a human element.
It,
it's really easy for me to come in here and tell the story.
Like,
you know what Joe,
like I'm the biggest bad ass in the world.
No one's walked across Antarctica and like I did it.
Even though these people died trying whatever.
Like those are the facts of the situation.
But like the truth is man,
like I'm human.
Like I have the wave of human emotions.
I've figured out how to tap into my mind in a way to do these things.
But like I still experience fear.
I steer,
it's feeling experienced,
doubt.
I still experienced the ups and downs,
but I have a way of actually being able to repo purpose or refocus that energy
into positive,
forward momentum.
I think that's what the difference is.
But I believe all of us,
all of us humans have the capacity to do this.
Like you're looking at me,
I'm like a pretty like regular,
like size of the regular looking guy.
Um,
but I think you know,
the muscle between my years is what separates a difference.
And they allowed me to do this more than anything.
You don't seem to have the darkness that I usually see in people that do things
like this.
Do you know what I'm saying?
This,
I then met a bunch of people that have done some fucked up things and they all
have some weird darkness.
Yeah.
You know,
I hear what you're saying.
I think for me there's a lot of this strength come from a dark moment in my
life.
Um,
you know,
right after college,
uh,
I was traveling around the world that,
you know,
I had no money as a kid growing up,
we're working class background,
painted houses every summer,
but always dreamed of traveling the world.
So I was like,
one day I'm going to travel the world.
So I finished college buddies of mine are getting like real jobs and whatever
Wall Street and things like that.
And I was like,
you know what?
I saved up $10,000 over the past six years.
I'm going to take a surfboard and a backpack and go see the world with my life
savings.
And so I went and do that.
I'm 21 years old,
you know,
go to Fiji.
I served through Australia,
hitchhike through New Zealand.
I ended up in Thailand and Europe at a time.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
Um,
and you,
so you're familiar with how much fire and fire dancing and various crazy
departures things that happen over there.
So I'm on a beach in rural Thailand and I decided to jump this flaming jump
rope.
And unfortunately it goes terribly wrong for me.
The rope wraps around my legs and at nights my entire bio body on fire to my
neck.
Um,
and you know,
in an instant my life changed.
You know,
fortunately for me the water's edge,
the ocean was 10 steps away.
So kind of instinct takes over and I dive into the ocean,
which extinguish the flames.
My Body's on fire to my neck,
but not before about 25% of my body is severely,
severely burned.
So my clothes were on fire.
Um,
but mostly we got severely burned,
was my legs and feet.
And so I'm in a place,
I want a beach.
There's,
there's no hospital on this and I'm on an island.
There's no hospital.
Instead of an ambulance,
ride them on the back of a moped,
driving down a dirt path.
You know,
I'm,
I'm in a one room nursing station.
Literally like the size of the room,
we're sitting in there like this is our sort of hospital,
it's like one bed and I'm just completely devastated.
And so that they put me under eight surgeries over the next week in the middle
of nowhere,
rural Thailand surgeries in a tiny little shack.
And the,
basically there's a cat running around my bed every time I come out of there,
you know,
quote unquote Icu,
there's a cat running around my bed and across my chest.
And the doctors are literally saying to me,
you know,
in the,
in the broken English is they're saying,
hey,
you'll probably never walk again.
Normally.
Like you're probably never gonna walk again normally.
Um,
yeah,
there,
there's a photo of that.
I think if you click over on,
on that to the second one,
it actually shows,
um,
you know,
there,
there's,
what the legs,
um,
so,
you know,
I was that,
that photo there with those legs,
that's actually eight weeks after I was burned so that,
believe it or not,
that's like,
it's starting to look a little bit better.
Um,
all things considered there.
So,
as you can probably imagine,
I mean,
just the darkest time of my life,
I've been,
you know,
an APP,
I swam through college and I thought of myself as a physically active person.
And here I am like doctor saying,
Hey,
you know,
22 year old kid,
like you'll never walk again normally.
Um,
and to me that they're the hero in this story,
which is maybe why you don't see the darkness in my eyes and it's more the
light.
But you know,
my mother is really the,
the heroine of this tale,
which is she,
she arrived to my bedside around day five,
you know,
flies all the way over to Thailand,
finds me.
Um,
are you,
are you a parent?
I don't know.
Do you have kids?
Yeah,
I don't have kids yet,
but I can only imagine as a parent what it's like to walk into a hospital room
and see your kid halfway around the world and this state.
Nothing you can do.
And she admits now that she was crying in the hallways,
you know,
pleading with the doctors for good news,
like he's going to be all right,
right.
He's going to walk,
she's crying every time she walked into my hospital room,
she walked in with a smile on her face and it's just air of positivity of being
like,
okay column like this is bad.
Like what do you want to do when you get Outta here?
Like let's set a goal.
Like let's get Outta here and do something positive.
And I'm like,
mom,
are you crazy?
Like the doctor say,
I'm never going to walk again.
Normally like my life is,
I know it.
It's over,
you know,
just in this really dark place in my mind.
But she just kept at me day after day with this positivity,
this,
that.
And I finally was like close my eyes and I just pictured like,
what am I going to be?
And I closed my eyes and I had this visualization of myself crossing a triathlon
finish line,
which is not something I'd ever done before.
I had swam in college but never biked to run competitively.
Nothing,
but I was like,
you know what,
the able bodied me sometime in the future is going to be not only walking again,
but doing a triathlon race.
And so I said it too.
I said,
my goal is to race a triathlon one day and instead of her looking at me going,
like I said,
set a goal,
but maybe something more realistic but it doesn't require you to be running.
Um,
she was like,
great,
let's learn about it.
Pulls out her computer and just literally starts reading me like triathlon races
are this,
they're this far there.
This distances.
Like I didn't know,
I knew nothing about the sport other than just like popped into my mind.
It's something I thought I maybe wanted to do.
Um,
and so that's what I focused on.
I literally have this photo of me with the Thai doctor.
I'm,
you know,
my legs are bandage to my waist and the Thai doctors like looking at my crazy,
but I'm lifting these like 10 pound barbells bells in my head going,
I'm training for a triathlon now.
That guy's like,
you're in Thailand in a hospital and I'm telling you,
you're never going to walk a good normally.
Um,
and so,
you know,
flash forward,
two or three months,
I finally get released from this Thai hospital folks.
Yeah,
yeah.
And when I got released,
I still hadn't walked,
you know,
I'm in,
I'm in a wheelchair.
Um,
I got carried on and off the flight back to Portland,
Oregon land back home.
And uh,
you know,
still it's still bandaged up.
And my mom says to me,
I wake up the first morning back in my parents' house and my mother's kitchen,
the house I grew up in and she looks at me and she goes,
all right Colin.
Now I know you've got this big triathlon goal,
but today your goal is to take your very first step.
And so she actually grabs a chair from our kitchen table and place it one step
in front of my wheelchair and she says,
today,
you need to somehow figure out how to get out of that wheelchair,
take one step and step into the chair in front of you.
And I'm looking at it like,
I don't know if this is possible,
but three hours later,
four hours later,
I'm still staring at this chair and I finally work up the courage and strength
to get out of this wheelchair,
take the one step and get into that chair in front of me.
And is the problem that because of the burnt skin,
it's not flexible.
You can move it and bend it and now it's a good question.
So basically what happened with the burn is it burned me so deep that two things
happen.
One is there was ligament damage,
so ligament damage to my ankles and knee joints.
And then the way that this,
the heat,
the scarring in the skin is healing essentially over these mobile joint.
They don't think I'm going to regain full flexibility,
um,
at full range of motion essentially in my leg.
So they're not saying you'll never walk as and you won't be able to stand up at
all.
Although that was like extremely painful,
but they just didn't think,
you know,
it'd be a magnet walking around without being able to bend your knees or your
ankles with like full mobility.
So it just was like,
you're not going to be able to have that back basically.
So sure enough,
I take that first step,
get in that chair the next day.
My mom,
it doesn't take it easy on me.
She just moved the chair five stiffs way the next day,
10 steps away,
you know,
every day a few more steps of,
and not to go on and on,
but basically 18 months after,
you know,
getting released from that hospital,
I find myself in Chicago.
I finally,
you know,
took a job in finance,
just trying to get out of my parent's basement,
like get on with my life at 23 years old.
Like,
yeah,
I got to get like a real job,
get out of my parent's basement,
you know,
move to Chicago,
take a job in and uh,
um,
try to get my shit together basically.
And I,
I honored that course.
I,
you know what,
I'm going to sign up for the Chicago triathlon.
I live here now.
Join a local gym.
Knew nothing about the sports still.
I'm like asking random guys at the gym.
Like anybody here race a triathlon?
Like I'm going to spin class.
Like how do you,
like,
how do you like take your shoes off and like run afterwards?
How do you,
like how does it even work?
I asked these questions and sure enough through that process I like train at
this gym,
sign up for the Chicago triathlon,
ended up racing the race across the finish line.
And to my complete and utter surprise,
I didn't just finish the race,
but I actually won the entire Chicago triathlon PDE,
4,000 other people coming first place.
So first try ever.
Wow.
What kind of training did you do to prepare yourself for that?
I mean,
like I said,
I,
you know,
I had been a collegiate swimmer,
so I was a division one swimmer,
swim at Yale University.
Uh,
but then,
you know,
the biking and running was completely new to me.
Um,
anybody show you how to do it or just start running and biking?
Yeah.
I literally walked into this spin class,
I guess,
but not like a,
like a hidden,
actually ride a bike.
So I went to the spin class and like start like met a guy and he was like,
Oh,
I've done one triathlon before.
And he was like,
I can hear you.
So he took me out on a couple of bike rides with his buddies.
I had this like steel frame bike,
I didn't know all of these like carbon wheels and aero helmet,
you know,
all these like fancy like triathlon type of things.
Like didn't know much about it.
And literally for a summer,
just kind of like ask people some questions.
This and what's funny about triathlon,
I don't know how familiar you are with this sport,
but um,
in a,
in a race like the Chicago truffle and there's,
you know,
for more than 4,000 participants.
And so unlike a marathon where everyone just starts at the same time,
you actually have to start in waves like a hundred people every five minutes.
And I was the 39th wave of 53 and so I dive into Lake Michigan and there's
people that are already started like two hours before me and there's people
starting two hours after me.
And so when I finished the race,
you know I swim,
I bike,
I run was Olympic distance triathlon so it was a mile swim,
25 miles pike,
6.2 mile run.
I crossed the finish line.
I don't still know I won the race because like people started before me,
people started after me and they take the cumulative time at the end and so I
like my grandma's there cause she lived in Chicago like gives me a big hug.
Like I'm so proud of you,
you weren't able to walk again and who you are finishing triathlon,
let's go get lunch.
And so like you know,
grab my wet suit,
my bike,
my grandma and I sit down to have lunch and as we're walking back to the car
she's like,
do you want to see like what place you came in your age group?
And I was like sure.
Like that would be cool.
Like,
let's go see how I did.
And we won.
Drove her to like the scores table.
And the guy's like,
I'm like,
Oh,
you know,
I'm trying to figure out a place,
or what's your name?
I was like,
Oh,
I'm calling,
I'm ready.
They're like,
we've been calling your name over the loudspeaker for the last 20 minutes.
I'm like,
oh,
why did I like do something wrong?
And they're like,
you won,
like,
like my age group.
And they're like,
no,
you won.
Like the whole race.
It was just this surreal,
surreal moment in my life.
I mean,
it was,
it was wild.
But it,
um,
you know,
for me in that moment what I thought back,
I was like,
it was cool to pat myself on the back.
Like,
Holy Shit.
Like I just did this crazy thing,
but it was more going back to your initial question about the darkness versus
the light,
at least in my journey was I was like,
wow.
Like this is a sliding doors moment.
Like what had happened,
had my mom not,
you know,
come in with this air of positivity and forced me to set this tangible goal.
Like I'm certain my life would be nowhere where it was today,
but then it's not,
I wasn't like,
Oh wow,
I'm some superhuman freak that can do these things.
I was like,
wow,
humans,
all of us,
we all have these reservoirs of untapped potential inside of us and can achieve
extraordinary things when we set our minds to it.
And so what it did for me,
it's just sparked this curiosity like,
well,
what else can I do if I set my mind to it?
So sure enough,
it was a Sunday when I raised the Chicago triathlon,
coincidentally,
um,
met who became a huge mentor and influence my life that afternoon.
Um,
a guy named Brian Gelber who ended up being my first sponsor and he said to me,
you won the Chicago triathlon today.
Do you think you should maybe do something about that?
And I was like,
yeah,
but I've got a job and I don't have any money.
Like I would need a sponsor.
He's like,
he's like,
I'll be your first sponsor if it's something you want to take seriously.
And so literally that was on a Sunday.
Monday morning I walk in and quit my job immediately.
Got It.
Two weeks later I'm living in Australia trading triathlon fulltime and ended up
racing triathlon professionally for the USA national team,
you know,
all over the world for the next six years.
So it was this crazy moment.
What happened ultimately with the injuries that you sustained from the fire?
You know,
all things sincere.
That was,
so that was January 14th,
2008,
so it's a just over 11 years ago now.
Um,
and I,
uh,
you know,
I ultimately have been pretty all right.
I mean I've got some scars,
but it's pretty faint.
Um,
was able to gain back most of the full flexibility in my legs.
If you look at my left foot is where the worst worst burns,
but where the rope really just like sat on my foot for a long time must have,
um,
that's still pretty thick with scar tissue.
Um,
you know,
when I'm in the mountains,
when I'm in places,
you know,
like climbing a mountain every second.
I did like pulling across an article.
The things I have to be really aware cause my skin regulates heat not in the
best way he and cold,
it's still just like,
no,
not like normal scans.
The scar tissue,
the scar tissue just is,
it's just carries the heat a little bit different for some reason I guess.
I don't know exactly why that was porous because it's exactly in the,
I'm actually in the early days for the first five years,
I don't get this so often anymore,
but in the first literally five years of this,
if I bumped my legs until like a table or someone just,
you know,
bumped a chair and immediately no,
nothing like lightly,
I would usually get a little cut there.
So it was just super fragile.
It was almost like,
you know,
class skin kind of,
um,
what's the but not the same sort of flexibility that you'd normally have,
but you know,
10,
11 years on now I would say it's pretty much 100%.
I mean the things I've done with my legs and body in the last 10 years,
I think proof,
at least that that my body is doing all right.
So I feel extremely,
extremely fortunate to ever cover it as,
as well as I did.
And you know,
more than anything,
I test that too.
Of course,
the,
the physical ability for my body to recover and the way it did,
but I think that,
at least for me,
started with the mine,
started with that positivity of my mother and,
and the duration of the many different things I've done done since then.